what's up peeps major things are
happening with the Batman including more
additions to what was already in
all-star cast so what does this tell us
about the new Batman movie let's discuss
shall we right now on the ketchup
Batman's writer and director Matt Reeves
has made a habit of breaking casting
news on Twitter and revealed on Monday
that Colin Farrell is indeed playing
Oswald Cobblepot
aka penguin aka oz apparently in the
next Batman movie that's scheduled for
June of 2021 sure do hope you like it we
also found out recently that Peter
Sarsgaard has been cast in a mystery
role although speculation is that he
could be a corrupt cop or District
Attorney so in other words Harvey Dent
better known as two-face let's face it
he wouldn't be a good guy and we also
know that the very busy Andy Serkis is
gonna be playing our favorite Butler
next to Ask Jeeves of course Alfred
Pennyworth he's younger than past movie
Alfred so it should be interesting to
see what his version of the character
brings to the table
I mean maybe we'll get a my precious who
knows especially because Serkis who's
directing the upcoming venom sequel has
also been the voice of Gollum in the
Lord of the Rings Snoke and star wars in
ape and planet of the apes
and now alfred so yeah the guy's got
more range than a rover I'm really
slinging these jokes today recently
leaked set photos from Twitter users or
creepy phone stalkers in London like
Jordan Lee show various Gotham related
vehicles that got the news trucks and
cop cars in production Jimmy foligno
posted this shy of what is possibly a
Robert Pattinson is Bruce Wayne on a
motorcycle or it could just be a random
guy trying not to inhale air pollution
and user Wade rabbit posted this shot
what a pure Sippy Farrell is penguin
complete with silver hair and an
umbrella but no top hat
that was my favorite hat all of these
actors and characters could fit very
well into what reads is calling a noir
style Batman film and they of course are
joining an already stat cast which
includes Robert Pattinson it's Batman
soy Kravitz is Catwoman and Paul Dano as
the Riddler I know I know
I'm so excited too and since our last
episode about all things related to the
Batman check that out if you haven't
already we've learned that John Turturro
has been cast as the crime boss carmine
Falcone in the comics carmine is a major
underworld figure and the characters
also appeared in Christopher Nolan's
Batman Begins and the Fox TV show got
them I'm a businessman
so one thing we do know for sure is that
Batman's gonna have his hands full with
plenty of villains to take on and with
the impressive amount of stars in this
film good-looking stars along with the
cast announce for the next Suicide Squad
movie also coming in 2021 it's clear DC
has made it a point to wrangle a huge
crop of stars much like its comic book
counterpart Marvel and for that we say
muchas gracias DC let's do it
all right friends it's time for us to
kick it over to you now how stoked are
you for the Batman and all the upcoming
DC films are you happy with the new
casting details give us a thumbs up or
down emoji and let us know all your
thoughts and feelings in the comment
section and then when you're done with
that head on over to Ryan tomatoes com
for more DC news and if you don't want
to miss out on any future episodes to
the catch-up hit that subscribe button
and notification Mel as always thanks
for watching the ketchup iron ass Prez
and I'm gonna go see what Disney
character I am on Instagram hi
[Music]